[Music]
be on TV so this is just fraud and then
I'll okay you're on TV tell us your name
how old are you Billy can you laugh
[Music]
my daughter and that's nice do you do
that for your daughter she must be a
huge fan
beyond its the Beatles where the fellow
little are
how does your daughter feel about you
getting back into the Princess Leia
getup further Star Wars Episode year we
go god I think she likes it but I
wouldn't have to check with it if she
actually didn't like Star Wars when I
showed it to when she was a child she
said it's too loud
her name is Billie and she's quite
beautiful my granddaughter my autograph
oh she's very talented and it works
really hard she's going to a that's the
name of that College and why you and why
yeah I heard a baby started with them
it's some part of the alphabet you ball
as I see you guys coming up there red
carpet mother and daughter I'm thinking
myself
what's your first Star Wars memory and
then bring it to this moment here with
your mom up here the first Star Wars
memory was my memory was me kicking and
screaming because she was begging me to
watch it I was like four years old she
put it on like a beggar they did you'll
enjoy her me because I was a girl she's
a beggar and she's bored you wrong the
penny way whatever so she begged me to
watch it I obliged I sat down Vic I was
like four okay moving past the family
battle general are you seeing this
she wears the Bengals of the family now
we're paying a little bit of a loss to
mama you know we can't not Ryan yeah we
got it you got it it's all about the
only one that ever started and it's a
real thing I wish I play the young
sister help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my
only hope
has your mom given you any advice at all
any motherly advice about how to deal
with the starter with the same aspect
what would the famous baton I just like
keep iron keep my head up kind of thing
and just not don't get too wrapped up in
it don't like read the internet um yeah
she's not big advice yeah I didn't say
that though she's lovely
just to like try and just remain
yourself and be true to yourself and
just like be nice everybody and be real
and not get too wrapped up in it
just be yourself all right now I would
say that was too cheesy she probably
have something Whittier to say but hi
mom
you
you